we're all quarantined though with our
family so I thought it'd be fun to see
how well we know them well at least
y'all Julie and Emma know each other
this is our little quarantine family
quiz so basically what y'all are gonna
do or I'm gonna ask you to do is I'm
gonna read a question and you each write
and answer and hold the answer up to the
camera so we can see it and we're gonna
see how many you can answer the same so
how will you know each other um are you
ready
right okay perfect let's start first one
what was Emma's favorite lullaby as a
child oh okay right cutest this is my my
guess anyway to me and I see that to my
kids that's ours okay so next question
what did Emma get in the most trouble
for as a teenager
well done it hiding them this is what I
remember getting grounded yeah okay next
question what was Emma's favorite Julie
Andrews movie growing up
oh I have to answer that verbally can I
do that I don't know what her favorite
movie was of mine when she was growing
up and maybe she'll tell you but I dunno
what was the one that upset her the most
and it believed in a lot it was the
sound of music because she couldn't bear
to see mommy unhappy by the intermission
of the movie the second half
yes City into the first time yes and by
it's intermission should say right I'll
just go out and get some tea or
something mummy only pushing avoid the
scene made me unhappy so she interesting
that was a once movie to make a mistake
not many people know about this movie it
was a it was in the 60s but it is such a
beautiful epic saga about the history of
the missionaries of first missionaries
who came to Hawaii based on a James
Michener novel and mom plays this
missionary and she's married to it was a
joy to work with it's just a beautiful
fill minutes and she's summer and it was
very very hard work to make it was
either the fire or the measles epidemic
or the ship it CU or the storm or I mean
every single once we finished one scene
we were on to the next epic moment you
know so I might have loved it because
there's a childbirth scene and maybe
when I was a little I fantasized that
that was what it looked like when you
were giving birth to me or something who
knows my my daughter right now is
obsessed with allenbury she keeps it she
looked at me last night I was putting in
her bed and she said mom I have
something to tell you she's five and she
looked at me and she said I'm pregnant
and I was like I was like I'm sorry
where did you even learn that word and
what and
what she was watching and she said well
no you said when you were pregnant with
me I was in your belly and she just
wants to be in my belly again it's so
more that's like you're there cuz mommy
hasn't lost all the weight okay so
here's the next one
what was Emma's favorite food as a child
[Laughter]
breakfast even more wonderful what else
what was Julie's favorite drink in the
1970s ladies tell me it was alcoholic oh
you know that supposed to know I love my
team tell us she can write it I think we
always send them probably a brandy and
soda brandy oh I love martinis too but I
always go back to
especially when I'm really like I like
wine I like a pinot noir what
what's yours am i what's your favorite
drink oh boy well besides a good strong
cup of tea I like I like going to I like
her Sauvignon Blanc yeah all right I
love tea okay last question what's the
one time Julie most embarrassed Emma as
a child or teenager well there's lots of
things I think actually hmm there
weren't actually lots of things okay
go freshen I happen to have a mouth as
well my mother hates it anybody
something about you I loved Kelly it's
well I was a cocktail waitress and dang
it just doesn't cover the gravity of the
emotion poor letter words anyway I just
wanted to say thank you so much for
taking the time I know that this is a
weird time all right
Julie Andrews and Emma Watson Hamilton's
new podcast is called Julie's library
and it's actually available tomorrow and
be sure to watch Julie's green room now
on Netflix subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going